Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so much awesome
news HBO was the TCAs this past week.
They teased a whole bunch of really cool stuff
that's coming down the road they're more episodes
coming than we originally thought, which is
awesome this also news on the spinoff, that
they are now very definitely doing so there
is a new round of the game of thrones giveaway
that starts now it's for one of the enhanced
additions of the books.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video winners
are usually announced at the end of videos
when there's a round that's ending be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So whole bunch of news all of it is really
good is like the stuff that you want to hear
the make you feel little bit better even though
game of thrones is like slowly coming to an
end, so number five the HBO people were presenting
all their new series for this year to the
television critics this past week, they always
get a ton a game of thrones questions even
though they didn't bring any game of thrones
stuff they revealed that the show has not
been formally renewed for season eight just
because there still going back and forth on
what the final episode count is going to be
meeting we could get more episodes next year
for season eight.
Right now this year season seven is capped
at seven episodes, it sounds like a bummer,
but each of the episodes is going to be longer
crazier and looking back at the previous seasons.
I don't really think of any of the older episodes
is filler but more money and more action going
into fewer episodes sounds like a good thing
right now season eight is supposed to be six
episodes, so when they say there could be
more episodes I could turn into seven it could
turn into a just like a set number of hours
that Dan and Dave wanted to tell and it's
probably going to be a while before they decide
because they don't start filming again till
way later this year they'll probably have
some more news about that when we get the
comic con number for the money is also a big
reason for fewer episodes the HBO is happy
to spend it.
Each new season.
It gets more and more expensive to do game
of thrones because a doing bigger battles
there doing more dragons so.
Just for example, this is totally not judge
to break down some of the finances on game
of thrones during season six the episodes
cost an average of about $10 million per episode
that's about $100 million for the season.
The battle of the Bastard's episode was way
more than that.
So just for example a normal episode of an
hour-long drama on a big network like a really
big show is closer to like three or $4 million
per episode on a smaller cable network is
way less than that.
So HBO it just like shoveling money out to
do episodes of game of thrones there totally
happy to spend is much as it takes to make
it as crazy as possible but there's a limit
to that like they just can't spend 200 $250
million on a single season of TB they don't
get that much money from subscribers.
That's where HBO's money comes from.
Don't sell ads on their stuff they get money
when people subscribe to HBO's channel, so
number three.
That's where you get to the spinoff one way
to keep those costs under control is to start
a spinoff where you get to wipe the slate
clean bring in a bunch of new actors that
don't cost as much and you can do a really
awesome story and a vastly smaller price point.
So this past week, in the same breath when
they were talking about doing more episodes
during season eight.
They were also asked about the spinoff they
get asked about spinoffs every year and they
typically say the same thing you know, maybe
were thinking about it were probably gonna
do a spinoff this year though they said that
they would be stupid to not do a spinoff.
So if you're starting to worry that there
might be a time when there is no game of thrones
on television.
That's probably not going to happen it will
be a prequel but they haven't decided on what
that's going to be George R Martin is still
finishing wins a winter which he says is going
to be done this year.
We'll talk about that eventually to, but he's
been pointing them to all the best stuff to
do for a spinoff remember a spinoff would
have to go for about seven season so it just
depends on what kind of material they want
to mine and how much action they wanted to
be what kind of series.
They wanted to be.
So the big three pics right now are tales
of dunk and Egg Aegon's conquest in the dance
of the dragons if you haven't read the books
at 40 done videos about what the stories are
so I'll add some links at the end of this
video, but HBO in general sounds like it wants
to keep the game of thrones creative team
like the producers the people that righted
the people that actually make it like the
actual people to work on a day-to-day together
or whatever the spinoff is going to be but
last year Dan and Dave said that the main
series might be the end of their day-to-day
involvement.
So even if they do bring in new show runners,
it sounds like Dan and Dave would still stay
on his producers the basic take away is that
the people that give you game of thrones would
essentially be the same people that will give
you a spinoff just the behind-the-scenes some
things we get shuffled around a little and
even though he still finishing a song of ice
and fire.
George R Martin would probably increase his
role, especially at the initial stages just
to make sure that everything started off on
the right foot so if you came late to game
of thrones what happened early on is is that
George R Martin was heavily involved with
the first couple of seasons.
He wrote episodes each season.
But then as things got on.
Later he started to get pulled away by the
book series trying to finish that.
So right now he isn't as involved with game
of thrones on television as he used to be.
I would probably change with the spinoff in
a couple years.
So number two.
What about the stories.
So I listed the three big pics but it really
just depends on how much easier it gets to
do the CG dragons and really like any of the
other CG elements.
They include usually special effects get better
and cheaper each year.
So if you go all the way back to season one
and watch Daenerys hatch dragons the CG looks
okay.
It still holds up relatively well but it was
still kind of expensive at the time today
just a few years later, it's way easier way
cheaper to do that but today there doing really
big Dragon.
So there still really expensive, but what
they're doing today will be cheaper tomorrow
that's the big take away.
So it's not can be hard to do CG dragons in
a couple years.
So dance the dragons or Aegon's conquest would
be the most WTF action-packed stories for
them to adapt Aegon's conquest would be a
little cheaper, just because there only three
dragons instead of a bunch of people fighting
each other on Dragon back I can't even imagine
how expensive it would be to do regular Dragon
Rider battles.
It will be the best thing ever.
But would probably crush HBO's budget.
So on the other side of that tales of dunk
and Egg would be the cheapest because there
are no dragons they're just like a bunch of
big crowd because their lot of tourneys a
lot of regular fighting on horseback is a
really fun story it's kind of like a buddy
road trip story is not really a comedy but
there is a lot of comedy imagine Brienne and
Podrick riding around that's kind of what
tales of dunk and Egg would be like Scott
unfocused I didn't mean
kosher to, so was a really fun story George
R Martin said that he's writing more for those
characters in the future to but it doesn't
really have big red wedding level WTF twist
like Aegon's conquest or dance of the dragons
most of you guys seem like you would rather
see dance of the dragons than Aegon's conquest,
just because a lot of what Daenerys is doing
in these final season is very similar to what
Aegon the conqueror did so in kind to be like
doing the same story.
If they went back and did the conquest but
the dance of the dragons has all the really
crazy stuff.
It's about a very different event with very
different groups of characters.
But again all really solid picks.
What would probably happen is is that they
wouldn't actually settle on what the spinoff
is going to be until after the final season
of game of thrones the probably focus all
their energy on marketing season eight.
Next year and then as we get towards the end
of that they'll announce what the next spinoff
is going to be develop that and then there
might be like.
A year or two before they Premier that both
the main series goes off the air in 2018.
That means it might be 2020, before we see
the premier of the spinoff, but number one
when we actually going to get new footage
of season seven got a little teaser at the
end of last year, which is sort of in keeping
with their style like that like really small
stuff that they'll drop in December and then
January the first trailer usually drops the,
because when they were filming season six
it was like their normal filming schedule.
They had finished filming most of the episodes
by the end of 2015, so they had all the footage
they needed to cut trailers this past year
was different because winter has come to west
roast.
So they had to wait till later in the year
to start filming.
Meaning that there a couple months behind.
So with the first real trailer usually dropped
in January.
That means we might not get the first season
seven trailer until February or March because
there's such a big delay this year like season
seven might not premier till late in June
will probably try to do some extra cool stuff
just to keep the fans happy market the series
just keep everybody calm down till the premier.
So as of right now there still filming episodes
but they films most of the series.
They have is much footage is they need to
cut a trailer.
So it will probably be a little while but
they have a new series called the young Pope
this premiering later this month.
They might use that to promote some game of
thrones stuff, so we might get some more game
of thrones teasers while that series is on
the air, but as for the actual footage last
year was all about teasing Jon Snow's return
Daenerys breaking the wheel of slavers Bay
this year.
It's all about Daenerys's conquest in the
war for the Dawn so expect whatever teasers
they drop to hype up Daenerys versus Cersei
and Jon Snow versus the nights king, so everyone's
converging before a big season-long battle
with the white walkers next year.
So this is all about the characters coming
together clashing sort of like a war of the
five kings only now it's much more centralized
will still be doing weekly bonus videos until
the season gets here.
If you want to leave requests for my next
game of thrones video.
Just put in the comments I'll say congratulations
to this week's game of thrones giveaway winner
Paramore you and a copy of one of the enhanced
additions of the books please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details.
It was a new round of this video just announce
the winner the next time I post a game of
thrones video new Sherlock finale posting
tonight than a whole bunch of comic book stuff
posting on Monday while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that dance
of the dragons video and you can click here
for the Aegon the conqueror video thank you
so much watching everybody thought five I'll
see you guys tonight!